as your this entire line this whole  monologue he's doing is assuming that  she's only interested in men and that  she's only interested in what a man  wants or what a man could see in her I  mean I think that's not that's like  that's that's just not what life is like  I I mean I'm not gonna like not just  you're just making a lot of assumptions  and running down the street with them  and I understand the logic behind where  he's coming from like I'm not saying  that he's being like he's being  illogical but because he's basing all of  his from my perspective a lot of where  your sounding board of information is  is your foundation is heteronormativity  massaging me and the fact that like and  it's just not it's just not an alignment  but okay wait it's just not in alignment  with where I where I find my foundation  so I'm like pushing back on the opinions  that he has